- Leonard Bernstein, Eleanor Roosevelt,
Orville Wright, Albert
Einstein, and Pablo Picasso.
No other place can you find
the collection of people
in one miniature book, approximately
the size of a quarter, ever again
on planet Earth. We have it.
This is Colleen Moore's Fairy Castle.
My name is Margaret Schlesinger,
and I'm a curator here
at the Museum of Science and Industry.
The idea is fairies live
inside of the castle,
even today, and that we as visitors
are seeing the room as
the fairy just left.
So books are still out in the library,
the kettle is still on in the kitchen,
and the place setting is ready for
dinner once the humans leave.
Colleen Moore was an incredibly
successful film star.
She collaborated with the highest-end
designers and architects
and fabricated this castle.
It began in 1928, it cost
over $500,000 to create,
which in today's money would
be in the millions of dollars.
It has materials such as alabaster,
ivory, bone, opal, there are pieces of
World War II wood in the
pewter mugs in the kitchen.
The polar bear rug in
the prince's bedroom-
no polar bears were harmed in the making
of the polar bear rug, just so you know.
It is actually an ermine pelt and
a head and teeth of a mouse. Cheese!
It was finished in the early 1930s.
By then, the country was
crushed in the Great Depression,
but she traveled the castle nonetheless.
It was Colleen's dream of bringing joy
to millions around the world.
Over the course of 10 years, it traveled
on three designated train cars,
it went to 40 cities. It's something
that people would have
never seen before in person.
These are the chairs from
the story of the three little
bears. They are probably a
third of the size of a grain of
rice. If I were to take
off the dome of glass,
I would have to wear a mask
so I wouldn't inhale them.
Inside of the library, on the bookcases,
is one of my most favorite pieces,
which is an iron maiden. It's
a medieval torture device.
So it's in miniature and it's platinum,
and you can open it and there are actually
spikes inside, so it's super cool.
When you look at a room, you
see something new every time.
I do find it very
inspiring. I find Colleen
to be inspiring, and I find that
when I sneak down here and I overhear
the adults talking to the children,
it's just so exciting because
they just get so caught up
in the magic of the castle.